for a really long time we've been told
implicitly that our depression and our
anxiety are malfunctions
they're signs of being broken on the
inside and
mostly depression and anxiety are not
malfunctions
the signals that something isn't going
right either in your psyche or in the
environment
and there's signals that we need to
change and what we need to do is stop
insulting those signals
by saying that they're a sign of
weakness or craziness or purely
biological malfunctions and instead
listen to them
if you listen to the signal you can find
a solution
i am joined by johan hari author of lost
connections johan
welcome to the show oh it's great to be
with you chris you're also a very rare
instance
of a person who said my name right first
time i once waited for six hours with a
broken arm in casualty
because they were calling for joanna
harry to come forward so
i'm always so happy when people get it
right first time
yeah i think um i've said your name
or heard it on podcasts and interviews
sufficiently
for me to know what it is um so for the
people who are listening
you should have already heard me say
johan's name is
as far as i'm as far as i'm concerned
lost connections your book is
the 80 20 way to understand everything
you need to know about depression i
think you should be incredibly proud of
it
oh thank you i'm i'm really tough by
that and i'll start paying you
commission the
the more time drop it there you go i
swear to god i must have sent it to 20
30 people and most of them are going to
be listening
um so first questions first your book's
been out for what two and a half three
years now something like that
um let me think january two years ago
yeah so two in a bit years yeah got you
why is it back in the charts now then
apart from the fact that it's great
but why is it back in the charts now
it's a really interesting question i've
been thinking about it a little bit
i've been sort of in a slight frenzy
finishing another book
and um and actually almost certainly got
grown a virus so i've been a little bit
out of it and i've been thinking a lot
about
the the the themes of the book and why
they're really resonating with people at
the moment
so i guess i should just say what the
book is about and then just just very
briefly
which is really the book was the thing
that empowered me to write the book was
that there were these two mysteries that
i was thinking about
a lot of the time the first mystery is
i'm 41 years old
and all throughout my life depression
and anxiety have increased in britain in
the us
and across the western world right and
so has anxiety
and i wanted to understand why right why
is this happening to us
why is it that with each year that
passes more and more of us are feeling
depressed and anxious what's going on
and i wanted to understand that for a
more personal reason which is that
when i was a teenager i went to my
doctor i explained that i was very
depressed i was quite ashamed of it
and my doctor told me a story that i i
now know wasn't totally wrong but was
really oversimplified
my doctor said well we know why people
get like this some people just have a
natural problem in their brain right
got an imbalance you're clearly one of
them
all you need to do is take a load of
drugs you're going to be fine right so
they gave me
an antidepressant called paxil or
cerosat it's got different names
and it did give me some relief but for
most of the 13 years that i took it i
was still depressed
and at the end of it i was asking well
what's going on here right and
for the book lost connections ended up
going on a big journey all over the
world i met the leading experts in the
world about depression and anxiety
and people who have just very different
perspectives on this as you know from
an amish village because the amish have
very low levels of depression
to a city in brazil that banned
advertising to see if that would make us
feel better
to a lab in baltimore where they're
giving people psychedelics to see if
that helped
ask me afterwards and um i think the
heart of what i learned is there's
scientific evidence for nine different
causes of depression
and anxiety two of them are in fact in
our biology
right there are real changes that happen
in your brain when you become depressed
that can make it harder to get out and
your genes can make you more sensitive
to these problems
but most of the factors that cause
depression and anxiety
and make us feel like [ __ ] are not in
our biology
they're factors in the way we live and
once you understand them that opens up a
very different set of solutions
the reason i started to set it up to
think about it is a lot of the factors
that i learned
there's strong scientific evidence for
that cause depression and anxiety
have been super charged to [ __ ] in the
last five weeks or whatever it is
this began for a lot of us right so to
give some very obvious examples
financial insecurity causes depression
and anxiety
now that in some ways seems like a no
[ __ ] sherlock insight right if you'd
said to my nan or your nan
you know do you think if you're really
financially insecure
you're going to be more or less likely
to be depressed my grandmother would
have clipped me around the ear and said
stop [ __ ] wasting my time right she
was scottish that's
nice that's a good that's a good
scottish accent
it's the closest i can get to it you
know but but um
the i can say a lot about scottish
accents later if you want but the
uh all my um not because of my name but
because my mother all my um
negative thoughts in my head because my
mother's very positive person in many
ways
also very negative um happen in a
scottish accent that's hilarious
whenever i feel i'm [ __ ] up i'm like
what you're doing your [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this i got it i've got
to interject there um alan alanda bottom
one of my favorite philosophers
says every every bad inside voice was
once an outside voice
isn't it so interesting that you've got
a signature
that is is like embedded from something
that's outside this disciplinarian this
past
grandfathered in archived in right from
from this old
sort of era perhaps where you were
disciplined more and that's now what's
re
coming back that's true because both my
parents have
uh about say foreign accents because my
mom does regard scotland as a foreign
country
um so whenever she's really pissed off
with me the only time i've ever met my
mother
truly angry with anything i've ever
written was once
um i was it must have been when was it
2004
i was in new york um covering something
and for a play on the sting song i
called myself an englishman in new york
my mother phoned me the next day i was
like no [ __ ] son of mine as an
englishman
you forgot my own did to mel gibson [ __ ]
you
even now when she's really pissed off at
me she'll go oh
is that my english son oh god isn't it
mothers can keep grudges like no one
else
very true but the but you think about
that in relation to financial insecurity
right like my grandmother
and my mother would have actually
regarded that as so obvious and insight
it'd be like why the [ __ ] are you
wasting my time right
um so but if anyone does need scientific
evidence for it there is plenty
people who have a private income from
property are 10 times less likely
to develop serious anxiety than people
who don't doesn't mean there aren't lots
of other causes of anxiety doesn't mean
rich people can't get anxious
obviously um and obviously there's been
a big increase in financial insecurity
over the last
five weeks for reasons again so obvious
i don't need to tell your viewers
that is causing a lot of depression and
anxiety and one thing i'm finding quite
frustrating at the moment
is seeing people who are some of them i
know
they're all good and admirable people
but people who run mental health
charities that you know brought on on
the news or celebrities
they're brought on the news and they
said what should people do about their
anxiety and depression
and almost always they say well they
should meditate they should switch off
the news
it's all individual solutions right and
i'm in favor of all those things i'm in
favor of meditation i'm not watching the
news 24 hours a day myself because i
would go mental
don't misunderstand me i'm not dissing
any of those things
but that is so limited a set of
solutions as to be insulting
if you are worried how you're going to
pay your rent next week next month if
you are worried
uh how you're going to feed your kids
how you're going to
you're and it goes to the heart i think
what i think is the most important
insight of what i learned in the
research for lost connections
which is for a really long time
we've been told implicitly it's not the
goal of anyone
to communicate this to us but implicitly
we've been told that our depression and
our anxiety are malfunctions
right they're like they're signs of
being broken on the inside
and mostly depression and anxiety are
not malfunctions
they're signals right the signals that
something isn't going right
either in your psyche or in the
environment and there's signals that we
need to change
and what we need to do is stop insulting
those signals
by saying that they're a sign of
weakness or craziness or purely
biological malfunctions
and instead listen to them because if
you listen to them out if you listen to
the signal
you can find a solution and it's not
like there are solutions to financial
insecurity right
what the british government has done um
you know they've done some good things
in this they've certainly been better
than the us in terms of financial
support
but you know the the the um the single
best if you look at okay let's go el
salvador right el salvador is one of the
poorest countries in the world i've been
there
it's staggeringly poor the government of
el salvador has cancelled everyone's
rent
and everyone's utility bills till this
crisis is over right
now is no one watching your podcast
who's going to doubt the people are
going to be
[ __ ] ton less anxious in el salvador now
they know they don't have to worry about
their rent and their utility bills right
um a big part of what i'm arguing is we
need to expand our idea of what an
antidepressant is right
anything that reduces depression and
anxiety should be seen as an
antidepressant
for some people that will include drugs
uh but
precisely because these problems go
deeper than our biology
the solutions need to go deeper than our
biology too so
i mean i'm happy to talk about other
other causes of depression and anxiety
that have risen in this crisis but the
single best solution to financial
insecurity
in this crisis which is the single best
solution to depression and anxiety for a
lot of people
in this crisis i would argue is what's
called a universal basic income they're
basically doing it in spain
it's it's much less bureaucratic than
what we're doing
it's where everyone in the country is
given just a
basic income you're not going to be
having any you know you're not going to
be ordering caviar
on a basic income and there's lots of
evidence that that reduces depression
and anxiety
when they tried it in canada in the
1970s
they chose a town they said to everyone
in that not everyone sorry listen to a
large number of people in that town
from now on we're giving you a basic
income uh there's nothing you have to do
for it and there's nothing you can do
that means we'll take it away it was a
small amount of money it wasn't
yeah i think it was the equivalent of
about 9 000 pounds in today's money so
you're not gonna be able to live well on
nine thousand pounds but equally you're
not gonna be homeless with nine thousand
pounds right
um and lots of things happened almost
nobody gave up work which i think is
really interesting
but um the single biggest effect is it
was a massive fall in depression and
anxiety
right um massive ball uh in fact
mental illnesses that was so severe that
people had to be shut away in
psychiatric hospitals
fell by nine percent very rapidly
i think you might find the most acute
cases right
exactly um and and so i think
um and that that should help us to
understand
one of the reasons and i stress it's
only one of many and i'm sure we'll talk
about others
why depression and anxiety have been
rising throughout my lifetime and yours
right
there's been a big increase in financial
insecurity throughout my lifetime right
the middle class is fracturing and
collapsing
uh you've got a lot of money going to
the very rich and a lot more people
being pushed down into insecurity
that causes depression and anxiety and
for those people to then go to their
doctor and be told
oh actually it's just something wrong in
your brain is an insult to them it's not
that there aren't
real biological factors that are but
that's such a grossly simplifying
solution
uh explanation that misses a lot what's
going on and it means we miss out on the
most important
solutions yeah it's um like diet brain
so diet brain is anyone that's ever done
a cut or has been trying to lose weight
knows
when you start to really drive your
calorie deficit into the floor
all that you think about food all that
you're thinking about is oh god that
sweet potato
really didn't fill me up or i wonder
when i can next have my 10 calorie round
trees jelly or whatever it might be you
can tell that i'm dieting at the moment
as well
and um it's the same right you know it's
the bottom that bottom of masala's
hierarchy of needs
it's food shelter
and money is just a proxy for all of
those things right money is the
uh the root cause of food shelter safety
blah blah blah
and um yeah without that it's it's the
thing anyone who's ever been skinned
you just think this is a thought
and then at the end there's an affix of
but i'm skinned
this is a thought oh but money worry
this is a thought and it's the same with
this is a thought but i'm hungry this is
a thought but i'm hungry and it's
diet brain um i've got i've tried to
summarize lost connections in one
sentence
i'm going to see oh god let me see i'm
going to see what you think
your state of mind and mental health is
much more
under your control than you or the
medical industry might think
i would only change one word in that
which is i would say
our control not your control
that's one letter one letter
because i do think it's important to
explain to people that a lot of these
problems
can't be solved by us as isolated
individuals some of them can
a lot of them can't but they can be
solved by us together as groups right
um and so i would try to explain to
people that um
we can regain control collectively over
many of the things that have been
[ __ ] with us that are making a are
some of us anxious and depressed and a
lot more of us
a lot less happy than we otherwise would
be right
um uh yeah so but i think that's pretty
good summary i could give that thing
where david bowie used to have a um
he used to have a when he didn't want to
turn up at concerts he had a person who
who he would sort of send out
unfortunately we're not exactly body
doubles i think that i could do
you get me a quiff you get me a question
and give me a slightly posh
down down south accent and i reckon i
reckon i can make it work
right so um several stone and
uh it's funny you say that about posh
because my mum go back to my mother
at accents so both my parents were from
very
pretty poor backgrounds and um for some
reason even when i was a little boy
i had this weird posh voice right it's
so bad when you watch
our home videos right it's like my mum
goes i'm like five and my mom goes
your hand go on pick up that and i go
certainly mother of course i'd be happy
where the [ __ ] does this voice come from
what she does is she goes
she once said about a year ago she sent
me an email
and it said um i go han you're really
good in this clip
and i thought she's watched something
i've done that's nice i clicked the clip
it was the [ __ ] queen speech
uh i thought it was gonna be uh made in
chelsea or something like that and she
said oh this is you unmade in chelsea
um so i wanna go high level for the
people who
haven't read lost connections can you
just run us through the nine and the
seven
um sorry the um the causes and the
solutions
just just titles of that and then i want
to make it sound a bit weird
can i talk about something that connects
a lot of them yeah i think would be a
better way
yeah it's going to be yes this is not
true of all of them but
it connects a lot of them so everyone it
goes relates exactly to what you just
said
so everyone knows they have natural
physical needs obviously right you need
food you need water you need shelter
you need clean air if i took those
things away from you you'd obviously be
in trouble really quickly
but there's equally strong evidence that
all human beings have natural
psychological needs
right you need to feel you belong you
need to feel connected to other people
you need to feel your life has meaning
you need to your work has meaning
you feel you've got a future that makes
sense
and the culture that we've built is good
at lots of things right i'm glad to be
alive today
a lot of things are better than they
were in the past
but we've been getting less and less
good
at meeting these deep underlying
psychological needs that people have
a lot of them not all and i think this
is the key reason why depression and
anxiety
have have been going up and and you know
there are loads of different people who
explain this to me in all sorts of
different ways
but the moment when it really
emotionally fell into place for me
was when i went to interview this south
african psychiatrist called dr derek
summerfield he's an amazing guy
and derek happened to be in cambodia in
2001
when they first introduced chemical
antidepressants for the people in that
country because they never had them in
cambodia before
and the local doctors the cambodians
were like well
what are these drugs and he explained to
them and they said to him oh we don't
need them
we've already got antidepressants and
they
and he was like what do you mean and he
thought they were going to talk about
some kind of like herbal
remedy like i don't know jinko bilobus
and john's wort something like that
instead they told him a story there was
a farmer
in their community who worked in the
rice fields
and one day he stood on a landmine left
over from the wall with the americans
and he got his leg blown off um
so they gave him physical therapy they
gave him an artificial leg and after a
while he went back to work in the rice
fields
but apparently it's really painful to
work under water when you've got an
artificial limb
and i'm guessing it's quite traumatic to
go back and work in a field where you
got blown up
the guy started to cry all day after a
while he refused to get out of bed he
developed classic depression
this is when they said to dr summerfield
well that's when we gave him an
antidepressant
and he said what was it and
they explained that they went and sat
with him
they listened to him they realized that
his pain made sense
right it had causes in his life but
actually when he sat down with him were
entirely understandable
and one of the doctors figured after
listening to him
you know if we bought this guy a cow he
could become a dairy farmer he wouldn't
be in this position that was [ __ ] him
up so much
so they bought him a cow within a couple
of weeks
he stopped crying with a couple of
months his depression was gone they said
to dr summerfield
so you see doctor that cow that was an
antidepressant
that's what you mean right now if you'd
be raised to think about depression the
way we have that sounds like a joke
right i
i went to my doctor for an
antidepressant she gave me a cow
but what those cambodian doctors knew
intuitively is what the leading medical
body in the whole world
the world health organization has been
trying to explain to us for years right
if you're depressed if you're anxious
you're not weak you're not crazy you're
not in the mess
the main a machine with broken parts
right you're a human being
with unmet needs and what you need and
deserve
is support to get those deeper needs met
and the reason why i say
our rather than your is because that
farmer on his own could not have solved
that problem right
he needed people around him to help him
figure out what had gone wrong
and more importantly to think of a
solution and build a solution with him
and i think so many of the problems we
face
in a way you know when you explain these
causes to people
i mean let's think about another one a
really obvious one that's risen in the
last five weeks loneliness right
it's not rocket science when you explain
to someone
if you're lonely you're more likely to
become depressed right but i remember
it's funny i remember when i remember
the night before my book came out
i was sitting with one of my best mates
and we were talking about it and you
know when a book comes out you
you always think about how people are
going to react and i said
i think most people are gonna say you
know obviously there's interesting stuff
that people could learn
and lots of stories and facts and people
they won't know about in the book but i
thought
some of the ideas i thought they're
gonna go well no [ __ ] sherlock why the
[ __ ]
did we what we needed you to tell us
that loneliness and financial insecurity
causes depression right this is really
obvious
and then the book came out and i kept
being introduced in radio interviews and
things would go
well we're now going to talk to johan
hari who's written this incredibly
controversial
new book i wanna i wanna interject there
johan so
two things first thing being
the best books tell you a story that you
already know
is a universal atomic habits by james
clear one of the best books that i've
read over the last few years
i knew everything that was in that book
but no one had synthesized it
put it across with those examples and
put it in a single unit
right that makes a big difference second
thing
reason that i think people see lost
connections as controversial
is that it puts the locus of control
onto the individual from an individual's
perspective you're hearing stories of
snowflake
generation and helicopter parenting and
all this sort of stuff lack of
sovereignty lack of high agency no
upward mobility
people wanting the state an increase in
socialism and sort of leftist thought
where people want the state to give them
as much as they can and do the problems
fix the problems for them
i think it shines a bright light in a
very ugly mirror
onto some of the things that people are
doing that can affect their own
mood now again neither of us both both
of us have suffered depressive
depressive episodes and depression in
our lives neither of us are saying that
depression is in
an easy mistress to bear right like it
is an existential crisis that feels like
you're drowning in thought
um but being told that you have
that we have more control over our
mental health
than we might have thought
it makes you become the architect
or more of the architect of your own
suffering and
that's quite uncomfortable for people
it's interesting i
i'm thinking about what you're saying
because i think there's
i think i put it slightly differently i
think it's
if you're given a story about your pain
right
even if that story doesn't work very
well at least you feel like you know
where you are
right and what's called the biomedical
model which is basically just the idea
that depression anxiety are
overwhelmingly biological right
biological flaws in you in the
individual
i think because people have been told
that story for
so long it becomes a and
i don't say it separately for me it
became part of how i saw myself it
became part of how i
how i um how i
understood the world in built right yeah
and if someone and
by the way it's not that those insights
are totally wrong right there are real
biological factors
but if someone comes along and says
um that's true but actually and it's not
just me saying this it's the leading
medical body in the world the world
health organization
actually these problems are mostly
social problems and we
mostly need to deal with them together
you know as individuals and as groups
um it's very
painful to make the transition from one
story about your distress to another
it's disorientating the analogy i was i
thought of i think when i was learning
this because it was destabilizing for me
was like if you feel like you understand
your pain even if you feel like [ __ ] but
you understand it
to me it's like there's a dog a wild dog
but it's on a leash
right and that moment of switching
stories
of seeing that something much more
complex and i think interesting and
empowering is going on
is like a moment when the dog is let off
the leash right
and and that's a very disorientating
moment but
actually i wanted to ask you about this
chris because i i'm really interested in
what you think about this
i was thinking about this in relation to
love island and reality
tv that i think for me one of the
interesting things
i've been thinking about a bit in the
last few weeks but it's a big part of
the book
is i think one of the things we can get
from this crisis
is an understanding of what had gone
wrong with our values
so there's and this for me was one of
the most challenging things that i
learned about in the research for lost
connections
and i could see how much it had played
out in my own life
so um everyone knows that junk food has
taken over our diets and made us
physically sick right as you can see
from my chin so i'm not immune to this
temptation
i'm really pissed off that kfc has some
kfc's have reopened
but not within a delivery radius of me
but the
um but just like and it's funny i got a
message from someone on facebook the
other day i hadn't seen in years and
years
like literally about 20 years and she
said i don't know if you remember
but when we were 16 we watched uh some
horror film about the end of the world
together
and we talked about what's the point in
the collapse of civilization where we
would all kill ourselves
and she said to me you said it's when
they shut all the branches at mcdonald's
and kfc and they stopped filming
eastenders
and she was like just like so that's two
of the horsemen of the apocalypse
that's two of the that's two of the
horsemen of the apocalypse very bad sign
but but so anyway sorry i'm telling you
the stripes on so just like
junk food you know we all know junk food
has taken over our diets and made us
physically sick
in a similar way a kind of junk values
have taken over our minds
and made us mentally sick so for
thousands of years
philosophers have said if you think life
is about money
and status and showing off you're gonna
feel like [ __ ] right
um but weirdly nobody had actually
scientifically tested this until an
amazing man i got to know
named professor tim casa who did a load
of research happy to talk about but the
core of what he discovered is
kind of two things firstly the more you
think life is about money
and status and showing off beyond a
baseline of financial security where you
can provide for yourself
the more you think life's up money and
status and showing off
the more likely you are to become
depressed and anxious because it trains
you to look for happiness in
all the wrong places right you're not
going to lie on your deathbed and think
about all the likes you got on instagram
and all the shoes you bought right
you're gonna think about moments of
meaning and connection and purpose in
your life
the second thing he showed is that as a
society as a culture
we have become much more driven by these
junk values
um just much more they've become really
dominant
and i guess for me one of the
interesting things about this moment
is it's a moment when we can really
reappraise those values
because um it turns out when our backs
were against the wall
who did we really need who were our key
workers who's allowed to leave the house
it's not um billionaires right it's not
um
influencers it's not that people are the
biggest followers on instagram right
it's people like my grandmother was a
cleaner she cleaned toilets my dad was a
bus driver
um my sister was a nurse you know it's
it
it's people who who are doing the things
that have been
devalued for so long in this society and
culture and there's someone to ask you
about that in relation to
love islanders one thing that surprised
me when the book came out
was how many people um
who are reality show stars i got
financially there were three categories
of people who i did not expect to
contact me
who i got a [ __ ] ton of messages from um
wwe people wrestlers
uh reality stars and porn stars right
amazing
interesting to me that's the big three
unfortunately they're all female porn
stars which doesn't do anything for me
but
uh i know i was like where's all the gay
porn stars excuse me i'm over here johan
harry here's my dress
exactly but um the
and it was interesting because what i'd
get would i get all these messages
from people who if you looked at their
instagram pages look like they had the
most perfect lie
best life they messaged me and go i'm
suicidal
i read your book i'm trying to think
about this and this and this and i'd be
like ah
so i'm just interested in your
perspective on that that those values
and how
how did that play out for you in
relation to something like love island
real interesting question man i've got
about 20 different threads open in my
mind and i'm going to try and close them
all before we before we finish this
podcast so
um firstly i'm i was
very good friends with sophie graydon
who sadly passed away a couple of years
ago ex-love island contestant i'd known
her for 10 years previously to that we'd
modelled together for a long time
mike i didn't know personally but knew
sort of secondarily
um and people are associating that
those situations the fact that tv stars
have taken their own life
with some sort of a failing on the part
of itv
with some sort of systemic problem that
they weren't given of enough support or
whatever it might be
i've said this before but i'll say it
again itv2 give more than enough
psychological support to everybody that
goes on there you're given a full
psychometric evaluation before you enter
there's a psychologist
on site at all times who you have access
to and there is a full post show
aftercare thing
perhaps they're not super forthcoming
with it but they have a show to run
you know it's not their job to check in
on you every week and say hey how's it
going also
as the show continues and goes on and on
this is mean this is not me saying i
don't have sympathy for those sophie was
one of my best mates like
but she wouldn't want me to pity that or
say that it was somehow the fault of
itv2 right i know that she wouldn't um
people want to blame it on that right
and i did this tweet it was when
caroline flack passed away
i did this tweet and um it went pretty
big
and i said uh how many people need to
die from reality tv
before we realize that it's not the
fault of the producers
or the newspapers they are not the ones
who are retweeting and posting vitriol
on a daily basis if you want to find out
who is the cause of this problem look in
the mirror
and the problem is people the general
public believe that somebody with a blue
tick
now no longer has feelings or emotions
they're just like this kind of sounding
board to throw things on so that's kind
of my
my thoughts in terms of like the big
stuff that's gone on recently
um more so in terms of the values and
things man like my main problem
with reality tv at the moment is it
takes these people
out of the general public and then puts
them on a pedestal and what does that
say
to everybody that's listening it says
that you too
your path towards becoming two million
follower blue tick person with a a huge
clothing deal with this particular
company all that you need to do
is get on reality tv like that's now the
path to itself so a lot of people i
think that go on reality tv
aren't looking for a springboard for
their career
they are looking for it to be their
career
and that for me is is um is a challenge
i i don't
think necessarily that kids who are
growing up at 14 years old
should be looking to love island as the
pinnacle like the zenith of what their
career aspirations should be and yet i
know that that's the case
i was away in dubai with my dad a couple
of years ago and we were sat down with
um a young family we got put in it's
when you go on one of those tours
together and you get put in a car and
it's like
mum and dad and a young kid and 18 year
old daughter
and uh dad we're talking about just so
what do you do what do you do what are
you doing this that any other
and i was oh i'll run club nights and i
do this just give a brief brief overview
of stuff and there was a bunch of stuff
in there that i thought was super
interesting and virtuous
but not really none of them battered
denying on them but i deny it
playing cricket for durham back in the
day even though one of the kids play
crooked fedora i'm running the battery
tonight the podcast or the other bits
and pieces
halfway through the night my dad dropped
oh and chris was on love island
that was it rest of the night that's all
i wanted to talk about and i thought
that is a misalignment of values as far
as i'm concerned
that is being something which
literally is essentially by chance
being put on a pedestal significantly
higher than things which
uh require genuine uh work ethic
and sort of virtue and value to get to
um so that's my thing to do with love
island and i've also got something
that um relates back to what you were
saying before
to do with how people like to try and um
they want to make sense right they want
to have a story to tell themselves and
why they have comfort in a story and
this is the third time i'm going to drop
this same psychological effect
on the podcast so the listeners should
know by now but they might not
uh it's something called compensatory
control have you heard of this
a little bit yeah yeah cool so matthew
syed and the times talked about this
and what he said was that when there is
a period of uncertainty
people much prefer to give something a
story
than to believe that it could happen by
chance so one of the
experiments that was done was people
that were given an uncertain medical
diagnosis
were much more likely to see patterns in
a meaningless screen of static
than those that weren't and it's used it
was used by matthew syed to explain
why there's a proliferation of 5g
conspiracy theories and
stuff like that at the moment because it
is significantly easier
to believe that this global pandemic was
caused by the plans of some malign
scientists than by the transmutation of
a silly little microbe
and um as soon as i saw that it has got
so that
compensatory control has so many
wide-ranging implications i think that's
really interesting
i want to go back to the love island
thing in a second if we can but that's
so interesting because
i think what there's michael marmar
who's a professor a brilliant australian
professor who studied lots of
aspects of health and depression said to
me
at the heart of so much depression is a
lack of control and i think it's
interesting
um we live in a society and culture
where people have
very limited control over their lives
right um
and people have been actually
systematically denied it so i'll give a
a
an obvious example which is michael
marmot did
he's an australian like i said an
australian scientist who made a real
breakthrough in the 1970s so i had
noticed
that loads of the people i know who are
depressed and anxious their depression
and anxiety focuses around their work
right i was like well am i maybe people
i know are unusual so i looked at the
science on this and they're polling
actually it's really striking
so 13 of people like
their work most of the time 63 percent
of what they called sleep working you
don't like it you don't hate it you
still get through it
and uh i think it was 23 [ __ ] hate
their jobs right
it's quite striking right that means
you're almost twice as likely to hate
your job as to love your job
and the vast majority of people are not
enjoying the thing they're doing most of
the time
so i started to think well could this
bear some relationship to our depression
and anxiety crisis
and that's when i learned about and went
to interview professor marmot
so he had basically discovered the 1970s
the single biggest factor
that causes depression at work not the
only one but the biggest factor by a
long way
is if you go to work tomorrow morning
you have low or no
control over your work right so if you
go in and you're like a robot on a
machine
an assembly line right so you can't use
your creativity you can't use your
intelligence you can't
you just got to do what you're told and
you're told by your boss and that's why
you have to do it
um and and it's really i think so and
workplaces have
now very controlled you know people are
living under the tyranny of email
um and and i think
um i think it's one reason actually this
lack of control is one reason why
slogans like take back control the
brexit um
slogan which uh uh resonates so deeply
people at a very deep level feel they
don't have control over their lives
now i leaving the european union hasn't
given anyone back any control over
anything
as you probably guessed my my views
about that but whatever you think about
that
i think it does help us to understand
why these things resonate and it's
really interesting because there is a
solution to that right a very simple
solution it's a big change but it's in
some ways simple
to understand it i want to interview um
a group of people in baltimore uh one of
them was called meredith keough
and meredith was when i met her she was
in her
uh early late 20s early 30s and meredith
used to go to bed every sunday night
just sick with anxiety right
she had a kind of administrative job it
wasn't the worst job in the world right
she would tell you she wasn't being
bullied or anything but
she just it was really boring and she
couldn't bear the thought this was going
to be the next 30 years of her life and
more than that 50 years whatever
um so one day with her uh her husband
josh
and her friends they did this really
quite bold thing josh had worked in bike
stores in baltimore since he was like
15.
and especially in the us you know low
income jobs
you don't have health care you don't
even have guaranteed holiday time
you know it's just really insecure
brutal you can be fired at any moment
you've got no rights at work
and um one day josh and his the
colleagues he worked with in this bike
store
said to themselves what does our boss
actually do
right they their boss wasn't a [ __ ]
or anything but they were like
we seem to do all the work and he seems
to make all the money right
so they decided they were gonna do
something bold
uh they set up a bike store of their own
but this bike store worked on a
different principle
so the place they'd worked before was
like where most people watching this
will work
a corporation right you've got a boss at
the top and
everyone has to pretty much do what he
says or you leave you know you can rebel
a little bit but it's pretty limited
um that's actually a very recent human
invention and it goes back a little bit
more than 100 years
they decided they were going to build
their bike shop around an older idea
so their bike shop is what's called a
democratic cooperative
so they don't have a boss uh they make
decisions about the business together
they have a meeting once every couple of
weeks to vote if they don't agree in
practice they agree
most of the time they share all the
proceeds the money according to how much
they work some do a little bit more work
than others
um they um they share out the good tasks
and the shitty tasks so no one gets
stuck with
all the [ __ ] tasks and one thing that
was so interesting
and this totally fits with professor
marmot's research
spending time with them was how many of
them talked about how they had been
depressed and anxious in their previous
job
and were not depressed and anxious now
and it's not like
they you know they they quit their jobs
fixing bikes and went off to become
beyonce's backing singers right they fix
bikes before they fix bikes now what was
the difference
now they had control over their work now
that's still a capitalist economy they
compete in a capital economy they have
to have a good shop or it will shut down
right
but the the you the unit that's
competing
is a democratic cooperative and i just
think about when i'm spending time there
and
other democratic cooperatives and
there's loads of them
i was thinking about how many people do
i know who are depressed and anxious
who would feel quite differently if they
knew that tomorrow they were going to
work in a workplace where
the boss was accountable to them as well
as the other way around
where they can control it where if they
can use their intelligence for their
task if something isn't working
they can persuade their colleagues they
can change how it works it's actually
more efficient as well a study at
cornell university
found that more democratic businesses do
much better because you're using the
intelligence of all your workers
not just you know you're not deadening
them all day so there's a lot of ways we
can
change the way we live partly that's
individuals can do that and partly i
just
i think we should get rid of
corporations i think everything should
be a democratic
all businesses should be democratic
cooperatives they're more it's more
efficient it's better for the economy
and it's much better for people's mental
health but um
i think it helps us to see again when
you reframe problems in this way based
on the best science
again you can see how that's saying to
people who are depressed and anxious
it's not that there's something wrong
with you right it's not that you're
broken
it's that we we fell into these ways of
living that didn't work very well for us
that don't meet our needs
and we can change those things together
right we don't have to go on
in these way it's about giving people
like you were saying before chris
give you a sense of power and agency
that we can change these things
and small changes some of them are big
changes but
the changes that are possible are
incredible and one of the reasons i
think i'm
actually very optimistic about change is
partly
because i'm gay right and i'm 41 years
old i've seen the world
if you had i didn't hear the phrase gay
marriage
until i was 21 years old right and and
when i heard it i thought well that's
[ __ ] never going to happen
right in the book i tell a story then
a really close friend of mine who
um i think about all the time when i get
into a mode where i think oh we can't
change anything
and i've been thinking about him a lot
in the last few weeks for reasons it'll
be obvious when i say it
so in 1994 my friend andrew sullivan was
diagnosed as hiv positive
at the height of the age crisis the last
big plague if you like
uh it's not totally the same a lot of
differences obviously but some parallels
and this was before there were protease
inhibitors or anything so this was a
death sentence right
his best friend patrick had already died
of aids gay people interviewing
struggles all sorts of people
were just dying all over the place and
andrew
decided he would do one last thing
before he died
he went to a little place called
provincetown
and he wrote a book about a crazy
utopian idea that no one had ever
written a book advocating right
and he thought well i'm never going to
live to see this obviously no one alive
today i'll live to see it
but maybe someone further down the line
will pick up this idea
the idea he wrote the first book ever to
advocate was gay marriage
right and when i tried to get when i
think oh [ __ ] things are never going to
change i tried to imagine
going back in time to 1994 and saying to
andrew
okay andrew you're not going to believe
me 26 years from now
you'll be alive step one great news all
right elton john's married
out john's married you'll be [ __ ]
married
to a man because that'll be legal uh
i'll be with you when the supreme court
of the united states
quotes this book you're writing now when
it makes it mandatory
for the entire united states to
introduce gay marriage and i'll be with
you when you get an invitation
uh from the president of the united
states
to go and have dinner with him the next
night in a white house that will be lit
up in the colours of the rainbow flag
to celebrate what you and everyone else
have achieved and by the way that
president
is gonna be black right yeah every
aspect of that would have been like
okay chris yeah uh 25 years from now a
transgender prime minister
is going to invite us to smoke crack in
downing street
with her you know i mean it would have
seemed like not that
yeah so it would be fun
uh the the you know incredible changes
are possible
and i think you know particularly a
moment like this when we're all feeling
pessimistic for totally understandable
reasons we're in a terrible crisis
it's so important to stress to people
that incredibly powerful positive
changes are possible
and we are all the beneficiaries of them
the idea of the weekend
was a crazy radical idea when it was
first proposed by ordinary working-class
people
in the 19th century now if anyone tried
to take away the weekend
they'd be lynched right there you know
um
my grandmothers were not allowed to have
bank accounts in their own [ __ ] names
when they got married right that's not
that long ago yeah there are incred and
of course things can get worse as well
as some people would have noticed from
the news
but you know that um it's really
important
depression is um there's a doctor
called tyrol harris who gave me the best
definition of depression that i got for
the whole book
she said everyone experiences
hopelessness sometimes
but depression is when hopelessness
spreads over your whole
horizon like an oil slick and i think
one of the ways you break that of course
it's extremely irritating to depressed
people to say hey
cheer up that's not what i'm saying what
i'm saying is
together rather like those cambodian
doctors with the
guy who needed a cow together we can
figure out what is causing this
depression and anxiety crisis
and we can deal with it right and the
fact that depression and anxiety have
gone up so much in the past five weeks
should at least help us with one thing
right no one thinks in the last five
weeks
human biology suddenly mutated to make
us all depressed right
the environment changed i have a
sentence here on my notes which says
searches for the term depression are 50
percent higher now than they were in
december does this prove your hypothesis
that depression is highly dependent on
environmental factors
yes thank you look at that we did it
to say it's important so it's not my
hypothesis it's the hypothesis of the
leading medical body in the world the
world health organization
and by the way we're all turning yeah
but i got it from them so let's give
them
credit uh and lots of other people as
well as others doctors and psychiatrists
and scientists but
the um who i learned it from um
but yeah no i think you're totally right
that that you know
these were always primarily there are
real biological components it's
important to keep stressing that i'm
happy to talk about them if you want
but these were always primarily
biological and psychological problems
and sorry i said again these were always
to a large degree
social and psychological problems and a
large part of the solutions need to be
built around
dealing with those problems and the last
third of my book lost connections is
really
very practical ways people i met all
over the world
from east london to sydney who were
to sao paulo who were dealing in a very
practical way with these problems
i want to i want to talk about those in
a second one thing that i've been
thinking
a lot about recently uh is to do with
the
self-development uh world which i'm
i'm heading feet into you know i
a big advocate of morning routines i
have a very routine eyes day
i do my journaling i make sure that i
have a morning walk in sunlight i do
you know i have a significant number of
structures
that um ensure that my self-care is
looked after in fact self-care is one of
the five
five uh key core habits that i have in
my life it's one of the key values that
i have in my own life because if i don't
do my self-care then everything else
crumbles as well
but i wonder how much of these
resurgence or the surgeons
in the world of self-development
is due to people trying to take control
trying to bring some order to the chaos
of their life it's like
a very macro version of ocd
you know there's certain things that you
can control there's certain things that
you can't control
but if i know this for a fact i know
that if i do
morning walk journaling meditation
reading
back rehab cook my food train go to
sleep on time don't spend too much time
on my phone don't use my phone until 4pm
all the
all the structures all these things and
that sounds incredibly artistic you know
to have these
like structure structure of the day but
that brings order to chaos right that
allows me
that wraps that around and i think that
it's twofold firstly
i think that we still as a modern
society haven't got over our fear of
death
and i think that we are trying to
transcend our fear of death through
the longevity movement which is going on
at the moment had dr david sinclair one
of the world's leading
doctors on huge huge name and um the
comments to that video i've never had
more passionate comments to it
why why why would people be getting so
emboldened
so so emotional about something which is
nicotinamide animide dinucleotide
supplementation and resveratrol at three
in the morning and stuff like that
why people getting so emotional about
intermittent fasting when i can have
douglas murray on talking about
transgender pronouns
and like people just sort of it's a
thing and then some people get emotional
about it
the reason that i think it is is because
people are desperately searching they've
lost faith in
in religion i think that secularism's
increasing and
there's the afterlife and stuff doesn't
give people that sense same
sense of comfort about where their
life's going to finish
so they're desperately trying to hope
that they can extend it and i think that
the
self-development world is perhaps
a similar way a similar way that people
are trying to bring control
into their life trying to create these
structures the morning routine the
evening routine
the way that they think you know
meditation practice oh and just
like let go return to the breath let go
return to whatever is present the power
of now all of this sort of stuff i think
that there's some unifying um
some unifying principles in there that's
really interesting i'm just thinking
about what you're saying
i think i mean there's lots of things in
what you're saying one thing and i i
don't think it's the biggest thing but i
think one thing that relates to that
i think you have to see that in the
context of
this explosion in loneliness right
so the there's incredible studies on
this
a study that asks americans how many
close friends do you have that you could
turn to in a crisis
and when they started doing it years ago
the most common answer was five
today the most common answer not the
average but the most common answer
is none right forty percent of americans
agree with the statement nobody knows me
well
and on those international league tables
in britain we're just we're just behind
them
and i think there's a thing about
in a profoundly lonely society
all an individual has is the self right
or at least they begin to believe all
they have is the self
and what that can do is begin to promote
uh so it can promote uh
and i'm not saying this is i want to be
clear the kind of things you're
describing like having a routine and so
on are extremely healthy ways of
structuring anyone's life
whether you're a lonely society or a
profoundly socially connected society
so i'm not talking about that i think it
can produce a kind of um
self-centeredness because the self is
all you have and i remember speaking
um i spent a lot of time interviewing
this incredible man named
professor john cassiopo who was the
leading expert in the world on
loneliness and
he sadly died recently but he i remember
he was saying to me you know
um why do we exist why are we here right
um one key reason is that our ancestors
on the savannas of africa
were really good at one thing they
weren't bigger than the animals they
took down
a lot of the time they went faster than
the animals they took down all the time
but they were much better at banding
together into groups and cooperating
so just like bees evolved to live in a
hive humans evolved to live in a tribe
and we are the first humans ever to
disband our tribes
and if you think about the circumstances
where we evolved if the human
if an individual was separated from the
tribe they'd be depressed and anxious
for a really [ __ ] good reason you're
about to die
right you're in terrible danger if you
get injured no one will be there to
heal you uh if you you can't hunt
um i want to interject your hands i've
heard you sure
i've heard you tell this story a number
of times i've always wanted to jump out
into the conversation and do exactly
what i'm going to do right now
um how is depression
adaptive or fitness enhancing so
um it's a technical way of putting it
but professor cassiopo said to me
depression and anxiety are necessary
aversive signals to get back to the
tribe
right okay so if you think about it i
get that i get that you have this
you have this yeah you have this
yearning to be around other people um
which is what people feel as loneliness
right it's like a hunger for
for company you know that's how i would
describe it what i don't understand
is why does depression make you bed
bound
why does depression make you not want to
get up and do things and
move that's what i don't understand
so i think there's a few possible
explanations for that there's a guy
interview called professor robert
sapolsky who's at stanford university
and a guy called uh paul gilbert who's
also got interesting theories about this
so uh professor sapolsky did this
interesting work a long time ago
with um primates with um baboons
and it turns out uh so he was living
with them on the savannahs of africa
and baboons it turns out male baboons
live in a really strict hierarchy so if
there's 40 of them
number three knows he's above number
four number seven knows he's above
number eight
and uh so you know there's um
uh you're very strict hierarchy and
where you are in the hierarchy
determines things like what you get to
eat what women you get to [ __ ]
um how whether you get to sit in the
shade it's a really big deal right
and what he noticed professor sapolsky
other people have written about this as
well is um
it's only the baboons and so the baboons
at the very bottom of the hierarchy and
it moves around
you you're not born into the hierarchy
you can it can shift
the baboons at the bottom of the
hierarchy often will behave in a
particular way
they will because basically everyone can
beat the [ __ ] out of them right
very rarely does everyone gang up and
beat up number one it happens sometimes
when they drive him out but mostly if
number four is having a bad day he'll go
and beat up
the person at the bottom of the troop
number seven is having a bad day he'll
go and beat up the same person
so the person at the bot the baboon at
the bottom is absorbing a load of [ __ ]
all the time
and one of the things they'll do is they
will cover their heads they'll put their
butt in the air and they'll just stop
moving
and they'll stop eating and they'll just
stay there and this is called the
submission response
right and it's basically the baboon
going all right you can't so you beat me
right just leave me alone you've beaten
me
i'm defeated i just want to be left
alone now right
and paul gilbert and some other
scientists have argued
that one of the things depressionism
again it's we're moving around because
there are lots of things depression is
and it's
we don't want to give a simplistic story
there are many causes
but one of the things depression could
be seen as is
a submission response right it's going
i'm [ __ ] taking enough of the
humiliation i've taken enough of the
stress
please leave me alone i cannot go on
anymore
and i think that's quite a plausible
explanation when you speak if i think
about people i've known who are
depressed
is that not for everyone is there an
element do you think perhaps
of being away from the tribe would
mean caloric intake is likely to be down
that you're probably going to have less
food less resources
is that a reason perhaps to be more
sedate to be more
um still so that you don't expend that
that's something i've been thinking
about
that's interesting i would want to ask
people who are much more who are
who are scientists on that but i think
my instinct is because it kicks in so
quickly even very small doses of
loneliness
um before you would have had a
deprivation of calories make people feel
absolutely terrible
but then i i don't but there's an
interesting fact about loneliness i've
been thinking about actually something
something professor cassiopo told me
that i didn't clock that much at the
time and i've been thinking about a lot
in relation to this period of quarantine
so remember when professor cassiopo
started studying loneliness
obviously to study something you have to
define what it is right
and at first you think that'd be really
easy everyone knows what loneliness is
if you say to someone are you lonely
no one struggles to understand the
concept right
but it turned out to be quite hard to to
define because
most people instinctively think well
loneliness is being alone
right but it turned out people
describing themselves as lonely
didn't bear that much relationship to
how many people they saw every day
i mean i thought it was weird at first
but professor cassiopo said well okay
imagine the first time you go to a new
city let's say you've never been to
new york and you go to times square for
the first time you're not alone right
you're surrounded by people
but you feel lonely right so he's trying
to figure out what is it that makes
people lonely if it's not
interacting with other people what is it
and he discovered
loneliness isn't about the number of
people you interact with
loneliness is about how much meaning you
share with other people
and one of the ways he helped me to
understand this was to say you know
we've all had the experience when a
relationship breaks down
when the other person is still around
but you feel really lonely
right so you're not alone they're there
but you feel like [ __ ] and you feel
lonely why is that
it's because the sense of meaning
between you is gone right so
loneliness is not about uh uh
purely about how many people you
interact with loneliness is about how
many people you
share something meaningful with right
i've got
i've got an interesting point there to
do with solitude as well and this comes
from cal newport's
book deep work oh i love him yeah
because cal's great although he's
absolutely impossible he's harder than
you
to get on a podcast and that that is a
that is a talent um what he says is
he talking about solitude and he says
that people require solitude
in order to be able to have time to
think to be able to process thoughts
and he said that solitude is not time on
your own solitude is time away from the
input of other minds
and in a always on technology technology
world where people say well i spent i
spent all of my trip to
drove to manchester and back that's five
hours yeah
you had the radio on and you made five
phone calls in that time you weren't in
solitude you weren't free
from the input of other minds and i
think that that's a very
interesting uh definition a very useful
definition one that i've been thinking
as well
and again to the people that listen i'm
going to keep drilling it into you if
you can
during your quarantine first thing that
you do upon waking go for a morning walk
the weather in the uk at the moment is
fantastic
leave your phone in your house get up go
for a walk there is some really robust
evidence that shows that getting
sunlight exposure
early in the morning is good for your
circadian rhythm it helps to get
activate your adrenal system it helps to
down regulate
your adenosine receptors which is what's
going to make you tired later in the day
all this sort of stuff you don't need
your morning coffee
and on top of that it is a period of
time where you can allow all of the
thoughts that have come up during your
sleep do you just burble and pop
and you can focus on where you're
walking and you can just think the
things right you don't need to obsess
there's nothing to do yet
you should totally you should chris you
should totally have on the podcast my
friend
isabel benkei who's an incredible
chilean primatologist
and is the most glamorous person i know
every time i email her and i'm like it's
about where are you she's like i'm in
the congolese rainforest oh my gosh
is that glamorous that's cool i don't
know whether it's glamorous
she's she's so gorgeous that even i or
my singer
i will put you in touch that she might
well be this is the only reason i'm here
right this is just a glor
a glorified groundwork session thank you
it's like a very
high brow blind date right i love it
exactly
i'll take on the silver black role in
this because isabelle talks a lot about
uh she did this really interesting work
she worked with um female bonobos or
bonobos she wrote bonobos
initially she's studying bonobos
initially in whip snake zoo
and uh she's very interesting on this
because i didn't know this
one of the ways that bonobos live is
they engage in massive amounts of
lesbian group sex
it's a constant ongoing sexual
and she she was the first person to
document that um
bonobos will work really hard to make
dildos
and she was in obviously in a british
zoo so if you give them like a bucket
they will break off the handle and just
start going at it
like it's a dildo um and she thought it
was hilarious because she's from chile
which is much more free and open place
when it comes to sexual things and she
thought it was just hilarious watching
all these british people with their kids
trying to explain to them oh darling
darling look away
exactly little little johnny asking
mummy what's that
but you know it's this really
fascinating thing which is so she worked
with bolobos in whips no zoo and then
she worked with bonobos
in their natural habitat in the congo it
was just at the end of the war in the
congo which i've actually covered as
well
and isabel uh was out there she was
living with this this bonobo treat
forget and she noticed something which
hadn't been documented until her
which is in uh
captivity bonobos will often
develop symptoms that look a lot like
human depression
a bit like the submission response you
know they just sit they rock back and
forward
they won't join the group they look like
they you know they stop grooming
themselves
they go to [ __ ] right and she noticed
this never happens in the wild
and she argues and there's a huge amount
of evidence that animals in captivity
um start behaving in ways that look like
obsessive compulsive disorder or
mental illness right parrots will rip
out their feathers
elephants will grind their tusks down
which are a source of great pride in the
wild down to like bloody stumps
um horses will start obsessively swaying
there's all sorts of things and isabel
argues a big part of this is just
physical movement
right we've become a society that does
not move
um if you think about the actual
movement we do we are the humans who
move least who have
ever lived right and and she argues
uh i think the way she put it to me is
in the book is sort of an
animal that is not moving through its
natural habitat
cannot be a healthy animal physically or
mentally
i think that's totally right but i just
want to go back to something you were
saying before i because i forgot to pick
up on this i think
there's one thing about love island i'm
really interested in i actually love
reality tv but i was away from britain
when love island came out so
good for you if you did me uh if you
gave me a uh
uh if you did gave me a um what'd you
call it
uh trivial pursuit series of questions
about
about big brother in the in the early
2000s
i could do a lot there but um but what
i'm interested in about love island is
love island the people who from love
island who've contacted me and people
other reality shows
led me to think there's this thing about
i think it reveals something about the
game
i mean the game about society and
culture not narrowly the game of love
island
that the people who are winning the game
feel like
[ __ ] right that tells you something
about the game it's a bit like when you
meet billionaires right
i've now in my life met quite a lot of
billionaires and i've almost never met a
billionaire who wasn't unbelievably
unhappy
right like achingly unhappy and
um i've met two that i would say we're
not unhappy and all the rest were right
and i think there's something about
because it's um because it's a game
that's a quest to be valued
uh for things that are
uh i would be careful because i don't
want to disrespect
throw it out there johan no one no one
in love island has
has uh so few followers that they can't
take on the chin what you're going to
say so just say it
i was like it's actually not really
commenting on the bonnie because that's
like i said it's about it but
it was it's a great thing to look
amazing
right and that's an effort to look
amazing right obviously some people
start off with slightly better genetic
inheritances with others but
it's an f and that is an achievement and
i don't i'm not dissing that
for a minute something i appreciate and
enjoy in other people certainly not in
myself
but the but but i think because you're
being
honored that i would accept that i would
exempt that because that's an effort and
an achievement but because you're being
honored
for things that are like following
you know
how did i put it i already know i
already know i know what it is right
yeah i know i know precisely what it is
i think i've got a couple of different
bits here
so um first and foremost it's the
dichotomy different i do a lot of
fitness i talk a lot about fitness on
this channel
it's a dichotomy difference between
training for aesthetics or training for
performance
training first training for aesthetics
is purely
subjective there is no objective measure
there's some objective measures what is
your actual objective body fat
percentage what is your
actual objective lean muscle mass
percentage stuff like that
but very much so when you're talking
about aesthetics or a physique
competitor
it's inherently a subject it's an
opinion you go up on stage
you are judged by someone you don't
actually know if your physique is better
than the person next to you because
there's no objective measures
let's go to the complete opposite end of
the scale which is power lifting
power lifting you pick a weight that
weight is the same for you as it is for
me as it is for the next person
you either pick it up or you don't pick
it up to the movement standards that are
prescribed
that is objective versus subjective
right
what that means is that one of those has
a very very easy sense of progression
you know where you are
and all of the progress can be judged
internally
without anyone else to help you along
the way so that's the first thing
second thing is when you get into
reality tv there is an
expected modus operandi right there is a
way that reality tv stars are supposed
to do and i
take great [ __ ] pleasure in trying to
break that stereotype as hard as i can
when piers morgan said that love island
stars are the most stupid people on the
planet i issued him an open letter to
come onto the podcast to have a little
discussion about it to see who was the
stupid one
um and
what is happening there is like the
particular love island star is putty
and there is a shaped glove an
iron-shaped glove
and that's the life that they have to
live and you get this piece of putty
which could be a u-shape it could be a t
shape it could be an eye shape it could
be a star and every single one of them
gets forced in from the back and they
have to fill all of these spaces
because you've got to do the thing
you've got to do the after sun
podcast you've got to do the photo shoot
for the
for the new clothing brand you got to do
the instagram hey guys it's chris here
from love island talking about this
like you have to live a pre-prescribed
life which in no way
aligns with the values that you brought
into it
so you're not being seen
and this is what this is one of the big
realizations that i had after coming off
and it was that i wasn't indulging
myself intellectually i'm
painfully curious like agonizingly
curious about everything about
absolutely everything
and i wasn't allowing myself to indulge
in that
the other thing to consider as well is
that
that uniqueness in everyone in the love
island contestants that may or may not
be listening or anybody anybody that's
listening
that uniqueness your life experiences
your genetics
the scars that you have the victories
that you have the failures that you have
all of those are your unique offering to
the world
it is your competitive advantage it
is what you can offer everybody else and
that's why i think learning to be able
to tell the truth learning
what you think how you feel what you
enjoy doing self-inquiry
doing introspective work removing your
biases
that's why i think that's so important
because the closer that you can get to
your truth
the closer you can offer to the world
what only you can offer there is no
other johan hari
there is nobody else who has had all of
the life experiences with the scottish
mother and this and this
there is no one else on the planet who
has that
and what that means is that no one else
can do the work that you can now someone
could have tried to create a proxy of it
an analogy an
analogous piece of work or you know
something close
but no one quite could have framed it
the way that you did when you wrote lost
connections
i'm just there i love that way you put
it that you're not being seen
i think that's so interesting and is it
fair to say
um it's not just that you're i had this
for a couple of series of big brother i
used to do their show big brother on the
couch
and i got to know some of the
contestants after they got out
and it was really interesting seeing
them when they came out and thinking
about that you're not being seen
with them sometimes i felt like it was a
sense of
i wonder if you feel this or tell me if
this is just completely off being
it's not just that you're not being seen
at some level you're being valued for
something that you're not
or something that you can't sustain do
you know what i mean absolutely so this
is a
a brilliant a brilliant exercise i'm
going to do it on younow i don't know
whether you've heard
brett weinstein and heather hayne on joe
rogan have you heard this one
i think so good right i want you to
picture
a man who is beautiful
but not hot
now i want you to picture a man who is
hot but not beautiful
okay right cool the difference between
those two
individuals and you can do it for the
people that listening can do it for
whatever their
gender sexual preference of choice or
both um
is um the difference between those two
that you've come up with there the
difference between hotness
yeah and beauty is that hotness wanes
with age beauty is timeless
so you can imagine someone like the
perfect example which sounds so [ __ ]
perverse
is a dame judi dench you know beautiful
have you got have you got a crush on
going dude look she's beautiful not hot
right so i'd marry her but i probably
wouldn't [ __ ] it like you know that's
kind of the way it would work
but so judy if you're watching judy look
i i apologize please come on the podcast
i'd love to talk to you about what it's
like to be beautiful
i think if you married her you would
give in you'd [ __ ] her eventually right
she have to wear you down right but she
you get that
you get that this is a subject area we
never thought that we'd get to a
modernism
it would be like a horrific remake of do
you remember um
uh you must remember this that as time
goes by that's that come from
jesus pornographic very very
pornographic version of that
so um yeah you've got this difference
between the two right and
the problem is and either way you're
just changing the subject for [ __ ]
getting back i'm getting back to beauty
and hotness johanna judy denshey's too
much in my head now
um beauty scales
beauty compounds right with time hotness
doesn't compound hotness wanes even
men i've by all of the red pill logic on
the planet i am
at my smv peak my sexual market value
peak right now this year this is
by definition the you know these [ __ ]
quasi-scientific stuff that they come up
with
um but everybody you should say that
because i got a call
from a friend who's exactly the same age
as me i'm 41 and he was crying and i
said josh what's wrong
and he said um i was just looking at a
porn site
and there was a category that said older
men brackets
35 plus and he's like we're now
literally
[ __ ] older what the [ __ ] has happened
oh no there is a there's a point at
which you become chronically aware of
your own mortality and it is
it's also there's a there's a time when
people start saying to you in the street
um to their little kids look out for
that man as opposed to look out for that
boy and i was like [ __ ] i hate that
but yeah so um beauty right it's grace
it's wisdom it's timeless stuff it's the
it's the things
that aren't in your face so hotness
that's what um
fhm i don't even know if these still
exist fhm and fast car magazine and
stuff like that loads of
references from the 90s and that's what
the girls on the front of that my
friends the idea that to younger viewers
we'd have to explain not what fhm was
but what a magazine was yeah
it's kind of like it's like an e-book
it's like instagram but on paper
um so yeah and what i think a lot of the
time people do is they signal for
hotness
not only with other partners but also in
themselves so they try and develop
hotness not beauty
and i will happily say that i have
some girl friends who are
getting more and more beautiful as time
goes on regardless of their age
like they're becoming more and more wise
they're becoming they've got more poise
they've got more grace the way they hold
themselves
the way that they're able to be
commanding but also soft and
compassionate
you know all of those different things
they're the intangibles
but the hotness that's what a lot of
people signal for in a partner
and like let me tell you if you are
signaling for hotness
you are buying into a depreciating asset
you are getting an asset which
by definition is only heading in one
direction you're putting a trade on
where you're going to exit the position
at a lower
lower than where you where you entered
it yeah essentially chris because it
goes back to it made me think about
something related to what we're saying
before about junk values right because
there's this moment so this is big
debate about
why do drunk values make people more
depressed right why does thinking life
is about money and status and
how you look make you more depressed
right and
one of the arguments is that if you
value people for their external
appearance
it actually [ __ ] up the quality of your
relationships
and there's a moment that really helped
me to understand this so in 2009
melania trump went to speak at nyu
oh melania trump fairly hot i'd put her
in in
hot slightly beautiful category
interesting
well that very much relates to what
we're about to say which is so she went
to speak at new york university
i don't know why there must be some
reason and one of the students asked her
um would you have married donald trump
if he wasn't rich
and she said do you think he would have
married me if i wasn't beautiful
and that tells you something it's a
funny line and credit to melania trump
who i feel very sorry for actually but
think about what that reveals about the
nature of their relationship right
so that is a very strong expression of
these external kind of junk
transactional right yeah so melania
trump knows if she ceases to be hot
let's say melania trump
just [ __ ] pigs out one day right and
just wants to eat
kfc or and donald trump she knows she's
finished she's out right
in fact as an interview donald trump did
with howard stern where he was asked
if melania was badly burned in a fire
would you still
love her and trump said do her tits get
burned
right so now compare that
so she knows charming lovely man so she
knows
if she ever loses her looks she's
finished right yeah and he does have
that narrow conception of hotness not
beauty i think
um and i mean this is a and and and and
he knows if you ever lost his money
she's at the door as well right compare
that to whatever you think about the
political differences between them
barack and michelle obama well i'm sure
barack i mean mr obama happens to be the
stunningly beautiful woman but i'm sure
they would say
you know well they would love each other
even if they became homeless and they
got fat or whatever right
so you can see how being driven by
an extreme focus on extra of course we
all like people you know we all like
people to look good
but if you you can see how that extreme
focus on it creates a form of anxiety
and depression
right in a way that um being valued
for more more enduring qualities uh
doesn't cause so much anxiety and i
wonder that sometimes about because i
see that with some of my friends i think
about
uh some of my friends who were you know
really like beautiful 20 year olds and
still look great
you think if so much of your self-esteem
is pegged to your
to your particular kind of looks you can
have that anxiety about aging in a way
that if your self-esteem is about
uh some other things it doesn't which is
not to say look i'm in favor people
i'm very really good with people and
favorite people working hard to look
good but i think
there must be something about um
to me it feels like love island from the
little i know of it and other reality
shows which i know about much
more are an example of a wider social
trend
which is that it's training people to
think happiness lies in places where you
actually will not find happiness in fact
you will find anxiety in those places
right a life where you are
constantly being judged by external uh
simplifying factors
um isn't going to be a life where you
feel good even if you win even if you
get to be
the problem is that you don't ever get
to actually find out who you are
you don't ever actually get to fulfill
what your
your genuine interests in life are i've
been asking people this a lot recently
i've been saying
people are talking about a lack of
purpose and meaning while they're at
home
because evidently a lot of people used
to derive their sense of meaning from
their job
they used to derive their sense of
structure and routine and blah blah blah
and i'm like okay tell me by your own
definition
what would have had to have happened by
the end of lockdown
for you to look back on lockdown and say
that it was a success
that's interesting tell me what tell me
and if you're listening
think to yourself what would have had to
have happened
by the end of this for by your own
definition you have everything except
for travel
and unlimited money you have everything
all the time in the world
to do it what would it be and so few
people can answer it
people i don't know i'm like you will
miss
every target that you don't aim at by
definition
by definition you can't and that's one
of the things so few people
know what they want and then what
happens you take someone
who so ambiguil girl that won love
island yerba
last year a good friend known her for
seven eight years her sister trains at
my gym and blah blah
you take someone like amber who is super
bubbly girl who i think
fits the the um what they need from a
contestant really well very robust
mentally got a great support structure
around her just
she perfect dream islander right
but then you say right okay you're now
going to do all of this stuff
and this is the things that you're going
to do and if that doesn't align with
your values then you have two choices
you can either continue to force feed
yourself this work
and stay famous but potentially
feel misaligned or you can stop doing
the stuff which is
keeping you relevant pursue your own
things
but have to face the pain of now being a
nobody because you don't want to do tv
interviews you don't want to do the
photo shoots you don't want to be judged
for your looks and blah blah blah
and it's that again it's that forcing
putty into a pre-made mold right doesn't
matter what shape you are because you've
got to play this game
there's a very very particular type of
person who can break the mold and still
win the game
and um that's why sometimes i get
accused of thirst trapping
on my instagram so i'll use
what few residual looks in my sexual
market value
whatever is repository that i've got
left um to try and draw people in to
then
link them to a podcast so i'll be
talking about like really hot in the
garden today i had a podcast with a
meteorologist who was talking about how
the world's getting hotter or something
like that
you know and it's like um trying to
break that
you still got to play the game a little
bit is what i'm saying it takes a very
very and even me i can't do it i can't
not play the game at least in part the
twitter game the instagram game the
facebook game or whatever it might be
it's not about um it's not
i think it's important to explain to
people
you know it's not that those things are
inherently bad in themselves it's about
are they part of a broad menu of things
that you have in your life right
i remember i went to the lost
connections i went to
the first ever internet rehab center in
the world
yeah such an interesting place it's um
some spokane in washington just outside
spokane in washington state
and it was really interesting because
and i think it helps it
helps locate some of what you're saying
as well because you think about i know
plenty of people have healthy
relationships with social media and i
know some people who have
uh horrendous relationships with social
media and
um i really helped clarify it to me when
i went to this place because
i remember speaking to they were they
get all kinds of people there but they
disproportionately get young men
and they disproportionately get young
men who become obsessed with
uh multiplayer online role play games
like um
it would have it would be fortnight now
i guess but it didn't exist when i went
so things like world of warcraft
and um i remember speaking to loads of
these young men and then talking to dr
hillary cash who runs the clinic and her
saying to me
you know you've got to ask yourself
what are these young men getting out of
these games right
i don't mean healthy people who just do
it for you know every now and then
when people become obsessed she said to
me
part of it is a lot of it is these these
young men are getting things out of the
game that they used to get from the
culture
that they no longer get right they get a
sense they're part of a group
a since they're part you know essence
part they're bigger than something
bigger than themselves
a sense they're physically roaming
around a lot of american and british
children
almost never leave their house the
figures on this are incredible um
they get a sense that people see them
and value them they get a sense they're
good at something a lot of boys in our
school system don't get a sense they're
good at anything
right um but what they're getting is
like a
a simulation of those things and she was
saying that to me i started to think in
a way sometimes i think the way a lot of
us use social media
it's a bit like the relationship between
porn and sex right
i'm not anti-porn at all but
if your whole sex life consisted of one
kid over porn you'd be going around
pissed off and irritable the whole time
i think that's
i think that is the sex life of almost
everybody that's listening right now
the coronavirus that's all you got oh
you let me
interject sex toy sales in italy went up
by 70 percent
wow there you go that's a step forward
i've already had a lot of sex toys in my
experience i'd say they did
yeah that's impressive the uh that's a
stockpile but you see the point i'm
making right it's like
um we have needs um
and and interestingly what what happens
if you think about the moment when the
internet arrives right
kind of for most of us around the year
2000 the internet arrives and it looks a
lot like the things that had already
been disappearing right
so a number of friends people had have
been declining before facebook
then facebook appears and it's like his
facebook friends people have been losing
status in the economy
prior to the rivals facebook then it's
like oh here are status updates to
compensate for your lost status
but it's not the thing we've lost right
in the same way that a
sex starved person given porn will get a
certain amount of relief
but they don't feel the pleasure they
feel after they've actually had sex
right and i think i think actually we're
really feeling this even for something
as simple as zoom right i'm sure you've
spent lots of time on zoom in the last
few weeks like
everyone else in the history everyone
else in the world and um
and it's really striking right being on
zoo
we're all in isolation being on zoom is
better than nothing
but being on zoom is doesn't feel you
don't i don't feel you get even 50
of what you get if you're sitting with
your mates right because we didn't
evolve to
to interact through screens we evolved
to interact face to face
that that that's those are the creatures
we are we have certain basic needs
that we can um that we can't um
you know just deny or supersede in
simplistic ways
a misalignment right between us and who
we are and what our desires are
and the environment and unfortunately
the environment is going to continue
changing
super super quick i said to a a guy
called rob henderson talking about
evolution in the dating market
and i was talking about the fact that
evolution at the moment is [ __ ]
pointless
because by the time that whatever
genetic mutation
you have gets passed on to your children
the environment within which it might
have become competitively
advantageous to have to adapt to has
changed so it's like
it's [ __ ] pointless evolution only
works with a stable environment which
moves as slowly as evolution does
when you have an environment that moves
more quickly it's absolutely pointless
right so i yohan i've got a list of a
couple of things i've always wanted to
ask you
i'm sure i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you
them
how would you describe what depression
feels like
i would use that definition we talked
about before from tyrone harris
we all know what hopelessness feels like
sometimes
depression is like a kind of
hopelessness spreading across your whole
horizon another example i would give is
something that i think a lot of people
would identify with
is um there's this really interesting
debate that happened
in the 1970s so in the 1970s the
american psychiatric association
decided they were going to give a
technical definition of depression
because up until then doctors have been
using whatever definition they wanted to
use right
so we're going to define depression to
standardize it across the whole country
so they did a really simple definition
it's that easy a lot of people would
basically guess at something like this
they dropped 10 uh a checklist of 10
criteria
things like crying a lot feeling life is
hopeless
that kind of thing they send them out to
all the psychiatrists and they say
if um any of your patients experience
more than six of these symptoms for more
than two weeks
diagnose them as depressed give them
what help they can right
so they start doing that but quite
quickly a lot of these psychiatrists
come back and go
look we've got a bit of a problem here
um if we use this definition
we're going to have to define every
grieving person
as depressed because these are the
symptoms of grief right
and the american psychiatric association
were like oh [ __ ] that's not what we
meant
so they invented something that was
called later got called the grief
loophole
which said okay if any of your patients
have any of these
six of any six of these ten symptoms for
more than two weeks
define them as depressed unless someone
they love has died in the last year
in which case they're not crazy it's
fine uh then
you shouldn't describe them as mentally
ill and so they start using that but
that begged a really obvious question
which was well hang on a minute
why is losing someone you love in the
last year the only circumstance in life
where you're allowed to feel like [ __ ]
and not be labeled as mentally ill what
if you've lost your job what have you
been made homeless what if you're stuck
in a job you hate for the next 40 years
we can all if what if there's a global
pandemic
exactly right so what happened is that
over the years the american psychiatric
association
reduced the amount of time you're
allowed to grieve and not be regarded as
mentally ill
from a year to six months to two months
now they've just got rid of it
so now you can be diagnosed as mentally
ill almost immediately after the death
of your
exactly so so um
i mean it's meant to be you're meant to
monitor the person for two weeks but in
practice they just say have you felt
like this for the last two weeks
uh so actually uh incredible joanne
casiotoro who's at the university of
arizona has shown 12
of grieving parents get get diagnosed as
mentally ill and drugged in the first
24 hours after their child dies right
and the reason i say that in relation to
question about what depression feels
like is
in a way i don't think it's coincidence
that depression and grief have the same
symptoms
i think what depression is is in part a
grief for your own life
not turning out how it should and a
grief for your own
deeper needs not being met and most
people will have experienced grief in
their lives and tragically a lot of
people are experiencing it now
and and and i think depression feels a
lot like grief yeah
i tweeted yesterday saying true hell
is when the person you are meets the
person you could have been
and um that's life not turning out i
think for me
i like the oil slick analogy but one of
my old housemates
described it as drowning in thoughts
it can be and this is interesting it's
one of the reasons why um
this is one of the reasons why i
interviewed a lot of the scientists and
and
people who've taken part in the the
studies about psychedelics
and uh which seemed to be a very
promising treatment for
for depression and i think that's partly
because some of the people scientists
involved say it's also why
being in the natural world can can
really help
because both psychedelics and uh being
in the natural world
when it's particularly beautiful and
striking uh
give you a sense of awe right you give a
sense of oh
the feeling of or is the feeling i'm
small and the world is big and that's
good right it's the opposite of the kind
of junk values we were talking about
it's a moment if depression can feel
like you're rattling around in your ego
and you're trapped in your own thoughts
moments of
or are like moments when you think oh
actually my little ego with its rattling
thoughts
ain't that important right whether i you
know whether i succeed in this thing or
failing this thing it doesn't matter
that much the world is biggest we feel
this when we sit in the ocean right
that you know the ocean is big and we
are small
we've got three things left that i want
to ask first thing
is how can people get out of an
acute depressive stage
so someone has had it it happens it
happens to everybody
where you just wake up one day and
you've just not got it in the tank
right what are some of the the tacit
strategies or how do you you know you
wake up one morning and you think
uh the black dog's a little bit [ __ ]
close today
have you got some structures have you
got some routines that you rely on that
help you to keep moving forward
i do but i think um
i think one thing i would say about that
and obviously
the book is really a kind of big attempt
to answer that in much more detail
but one thing i would say is
you know i would use an analogy right
i i think part of the problem of what we
do is we put the job of solving
depression
solely on to people who are already
depressed and anxious
and we don't do that with a lot of other
problems i think about car accidents
carrick says one of the biggest cause of
death obviously in
in the western world and we don't put
the job of solving car accidents we
don't say to someone who's just been
mangled in a car wreck
okay how are you gonna solve traffic
accidents
right what we do is actually because
it's a social problem we have a big
structure
to deal with it and prevent it from
happening right so we have driving tests
we have speed limits we have airbags
we have restaurant drivers we do a huge
array of things
and then if all that fails in a person
is more than a car crash
of course we take them to casualty and
we do our best and the doctors and
nurses are heroes
but most of what we do is trying to
prevent that problem happening and
that's not just the individual that's
the society that tries to prevent it
in a similar way because depression has
such
deep social causes the most important
thing
to do is to deal downstream with way
more of those social causes right
but so i would just say that i'll just
say that as a preface saying
of course that doesn't mean that of
course there are still things
individuals can
do um i'll give you an example of one a
very simple change that i made which in
a way is almost embarrassing to talk
about because it's
it feels so simple but it was so
revelatory to me
i went to interview this uh amazing
academic called brett ford
who is a um psychologist at berkeley
church in toronto now but she was in
berkeley at the time and she did this
really interesting research it's really
simple research
in some ways part her in a big team they
wanted to figure out
let's say that you decided you were
going to spend two hours a day
trying to make yourself happier would
you actually become happier
right and they did this research in four
countries in the us
in japan in russia and in taiwan
and what they found was in the u.s if
you try to make yourself happier
you do not become happier or in the main
but in the other countries if you try to
make yourself happier you do become
happier
and they were like how could that be so
they did more research what they
discovered was
in the us if you try to make yourself
happier in the main you do something for
yourself
you work harder to get a promotion
you buy something for yourself you show
off on instagram whatever it is
so we have an instinctively
individualistic idea what it means to be
happy right
in the other countries in the main there
are exceptions on both sides of course
but in the other countries
if you wanted to make yourself happier
you did something for someone else
right you just saying for your friends
your family your community
even people you didn't even know right
so they had an instinctively collective
idea of what it means to be happy
and it turns out an individualistic idea
of happiness just doesn't work very well
right
like we say that a lot of the reality
stars and wrestlers and and porn stars
who message me who've
built their lives around this
individualistic idea of success feel
like absolute [ __ ] right
i have never seen a more unhappy person
than donald trump who has won the
individualistic game
as much as you possibly can he's the
president of the united states he has an
actual golden tower to live in he has a
hot wife he's
he's won the game and yet he you can see
he feels like [ __ ] right
um so the way i took this on board was
it used to be a lot of the time when i
felt like [ __ ]
i would do something for myself right
and for me it was i was never
particularly maturistic person but some
external professional achievement right
now a lot of the time i can't say this
all the time because i don't but a lot
of the time
when i feel bad i try to do something
for someone else and i'm you know i'm
not oprah i can't turn up and give them
a car
but i can leave my phone at home and go
and [ __ ] sit with them and listen to
them
and in a society where people are not
heard
just the gift of giving someone your
attention and your time
is so profound for their for their
happiness so
it really stands out as well yeah i
think that's that's that's a nice way to
do it i
i certainly think that um connecting
with others is a big one
the challenge is that when you are in
the midst
of a depressive episode that's the last
thing that you want to do right like you
know it's a
it takes a superhuman amount of effort
to get out of bed
and that i think is where
uh the next action the next physical
action which is a concept from
uh david allen's getting things done
which is a productivity uh tool
actually worked really well for me but
you know chris i think even
even when you are really depressed you
can text someone and remind them of a
kind thing they did once
you can text someone and tell them about
a good thing they did
right there are very small steps that
you can take
that people are very rarely
so immobilized that they can't make
another person feel good in some tiny
way
and maybe it's tiny but you know tiny
gestures may actually make a big
difference
one of the things i made a big change to
do last year and i've continued to embed
it
is to just text people when i'm thinking
about them do you think about people all
the time
remember i went on a road trip with one
of my buddies last year across america
and i think about that or i think about
that training session i had five years
ago where such and such slipped over
whatever it might be
i'm missing my mate and um the friction
now does not exist between me having
that thought and me telling the friend
that i'm thinking of them
that's great i love that all the time
and i implore everybody that's listening
it will make your life and the life of
your friendship so much better and this
is coming from like
mr [ __ ] solitude only child [ __ ]
over here right
so if i can do it you can do it as well
but yeah you know you're thinking of a
friend hey man thinking of you hope
you're good
like it it just is it is what it is um
totally grieving next thing is
is the black dog going to follow us for
the rest of our lives
if you've got it is it going to be there
or is there a way that you can conquer
it
is there you know do you know what i
mean yeah totally
absolutely i think one of the worst
things we do is we tell depressed people
uh very often people are told you know
or you've just got some biologically
broken thing and this is going to be
your life
now there are some stress again there
are some real biological components to
this contributions
but actually um there's
very strong evidence that if we make the
necessary i'll just give a very simple
example
uh one of the heroes in my book is a
doctor called sam everington
you know he's a doctor in east london
where i used to live
he was very uncomfortable with the fact
that all his patients were being given
was
drugs and he he's not against the drugs
like me
he's not opposed to them but he could
just see that a lot of his patients
remain depressed
he set up a program really simple just a
gardening program
where they met and they built a
beautiful garden um
there's a study of a very similar
program in norway that found it was more
than twice as effective as chemical
antidepressants
in reducing depression and anxiety
partly because they reconnected with the
natural world
partly because they formed a tribe they
formed a group right
um so no absolutely nobody
is condemned to be depressed for their
whole life uh there will be some people
who need a lot of love and help and
support
to deal with those underlying causes in
their life but if they get enough love
and help and support they can
and that job is not just on them that
job is on all of us right i mean the
most important message i want to give to
depressed and anxious people is
help is on the way right because the
things that are making
some people depressed and anxious are
making most people's lives
less than they could be right so it's
not like there's this
this group of broken people over here
this lump of broken people over here
and then there's the rest of us who need
to pitiably take charity on them
if we deal with the things that are
making them depressed and anxious
will actually um enhance the lives of
pretty much all of us
that i think is one of the key
challenges that depressed people face
which is that the way the depression
manifests it's so existential and
symbolic and bigger than you and it
feels like a personal curse
created just for you right this is my
problem incredibly you know that's
partly the nature of depression but
that's
also partly because of the way we've
encouraged people to think about the
problem
right if you of course if you grow up in
a culture
where you're told you know i mean so
many of the ways we talk about mental
health are so flawed
i know look at several people who were
terribly sexually abused
who have a lot of distress about that
they act out over it they go to their
psychiatrist or doctor
and they're told they've got a
personality disorder that's a wicked
thing to tell people right that's a
that's a truly terrible thing to tell
someone your personality is disordered
when in fact
you're just acting how any of us would
if we've been [ __ ] horrendously
sexually abused right
so we've got to stop acting like these
are primarily
internal disorders within people they're
actually as victor frankel holocaust
survivor said you know
these are very often normal reactions to
abnormal situations
and there are some ways in which we're
all living in abnormal situations not
just in this period of
coronavirus but actually in the last you
know few years
so no i think you've got that question
is really important no one
is inherently broken and nobody is
incapable of overcoming these problems
it may certainly the case that some
people will need a lot of help to
overcome these problems and we need a
lot of
individual change and social change but
those things are possible right
think about gay people in the 1940s were
described
as inherently dishonest uh inherently
miserable
um had tragic lives even gay people said
that about themselves
because that was the reality you had to
lie otherwise you'd go to prison
of course you were miserable you're like
constantly having to hide your life
chemical castration
exactly and then what happened we had a
liberation movement for gay people and
an equality movement
and now know what you'd be regarded as a
pretty out there bigot if you said gay
people were inherently miserable
inherently dishonest
now right even quite homophobic people
wouldn't say that about all of us right
so actually you can see how things that
seem fixed and permanent qualities of
people
change when the social circumstances
change what we've got to do is
change the social circumstances and
that's the work of all of us i get it
whether we're depressed or not
what i think is interesting having had
this discussion with you today and
obviously having
been discussing with getting you on for
the last two years so thinking about
how this how this was going to manifest
one of the things that struck me
is um my
particular viewpoint on dealing with
depression dealing with low mood
is coming at you from a very
individualistic perspective you know a
lot of the time i talk about
um the actions that you can take um the
outcomes in your life
are more under your control than you
than you know um
so for me i again had you have asked me
the question chris how do you get over
how do you get yourself out of an acute
period of depression my first thought
wouldn't have turned to somebody else
and it
definitely wouldn't have had a preface
which was to do with
uh systemic changes society wide changes
perhaps policy changes and
and stuff like that structural changes
which need to be made mine would have
been
do the next action you need to pull the
pillows off you need to pull the
cushions off you need to get out you
need to have a cold shower you need to
go
outside you need to do this this and
this um i think that there's a lot of
value of coming at it from both
ways and i genuinely think that the
intersection of where we maximize what
we understand now from self-development
from introspective work from mindfulness
practice from stuff like that
um both in a more long-term thinking way
to try and make you robust and resilient
to low mood over time and to build
structures in your life which mean that
if and when that low mood happens it you
just bounce off it rather than you being
fully swallowed by it but also in an
acute situation which is where you kind
of break the glass
to do this thing which is like i say the
cold shower
the sunlight outside the glass of water
and the phone call for a friend that's
my kind of like four-step thing
um i think that the the crossover of
those two
you know the ability for someone to have
right back to the start that agency that
control that upward mobility that they
have to be able to do the things that
they can do
because to anyone that's listening you
know someone might have seen this know
what you do and think
i'm gonna go listen to that i'm gonna
see if this these two british people can
make me feel a little bit better about
my depression like
the outcomes in your life are far more
under your control than you know
there are things that you can do today
which are going to make your tomorrow
better
and there are also things that we can do
as a society which will make next year
and the years after that better as well
i think you're totally right i think
this a few things i'd say about that one
is
so if you look at the scientific
evidence for this there's three
kinds of cause of all any mental health
problem
um there's and they play out to some
degree in everyone
who has a mental health problem there's
biological causes
like brain changes your genes
there's psychological causes how you
think about yourself and there's
social causes right and i think you're
you're very much
um uh attracted to thinking about the
psychological causes which is hugely
important
um and i'm a strong stronger and a big
part of the book is obviously about
some of the things we can do about those
psychological causes obviously my
temperament is more to be drawn to the
social causes but
they're all real i'd also say i think
you're right
i think it's important to stress to
people individual change and social
change are not separate things
social change only happens when enough
individuals demand it
right so it's not like there's this
thing it's not like either you do
something yourself or you sit here and
wait for the government to hand down
some good thing right positive changes
never happen
because the government just almost never
happened because the government just
decides one day to do it
positive changes happen because enough
people band together and demand it right
and and and and fight for it and model
it in all sorts of different ways in
their own lives
so you know whether that's the workers
rights women's rights
gay rights all sort of things that have
changed the lives of everyone
listening to this thing but saying like
the minimum wage right which we now
rightly take for granted if someone
wants to get rid of it we'd regard them
as
barbaric you know someone to pay you a
pound an hour which used to happen
um the not so long ago until 1997
um that happened because lots of
ordinary workers banded together had
organizations trade unions demanded it
fought didn't give up
you know so so individuals
uh banding with other individuals create
social change so
there's definitely individual change
that people can do in their own lives on
their own
and in favor of also all sorts of
aspects of that that talk about lost
connections
and then there's individual action
banding together to create social change
which is very closely related to it i
think and i think you're right if you
don't do the individual change
if you're so depressed that you're
immobilized obviously there has to be an
element of individual change or you'll
never get to the social change
you know i mean the the thing as well is
nobody is coming to save you right now
you know you can call the samaritans if
it's a really really acute
situation there is a number for the
samaritans which i absolutely love
that the auto reply on your gmail has an
urgent distress footer in it
um i thought that was a really really
nice touch and i remember that from two
years ago when i messaged
you and it has like if you're in severe
need
here's the number for i can't remember
what it was like the samaritans or
something
um but social change takes time systemic
change takes time
and like i say there are things that you
can do right now that will make tomorrow
better um so i said there's three
questions and this is this
this is the final one and it might be
the one that you're gonna have to dip
around the most
you've just finished a new book what can
you tell us
what can you tell us about the new book
uh almost nothing but i can tell you how
long it's taken can you tell us
yeah well because uh the expensive bit
of my books is to travel so i tend to
research quite a lot of subjects just as
well that you got that done before now
i know thank god um so i'm i can tell
you the rangers
i'm um writing a book about why so many
people are having troubles focusing and
paying attention
i'm writing a book about las vegas but i
can't tell anything about that it's a
very specific story about
something insane that's happening in las
vegas and i'm really pissed off that i'm
not there at the moment because there
are developments on it but um
and uh i'm writing a biography of the
great american
thinker noam chomsky so i'm not quite
the attention book is done but i'm not
quite sure what order all the other
stuff will happen in
but um but yeah that's my that's the
stuff i'm working on now
that's awesome that's so cool man uh oh
look johan today's been everything i
wanted it's definitely been worth
waiting two years to finally
thanks very much chris i really
appreciate it i really enjoyed talking
to you thank you for engaging so deeply
with the book and
i was going to say for anyone listening
if you want to um because people got a
lot of time stuck at home
if you want to listen to the audio of
interviews with lots of the people that
i've referred to
it's all on the website so you can
either if you go to
thelostconnections.com
you can find out where to buy the book
the audiobook and
uh take a quiz to see how much you know
about causes of depression and anxiety
but you can more importantly listen to
for free
loads of interviews with the people
we've been talking about and and loads
more people that we haven't mentioned
that's like the dvd extras that's
exactly what it is yeah that's cool as
[ __ ] and also
um what's my favorite one so i think
your episode on joe rogan when you did
chasing the screen when you talked about
uh drug and alcohol problems i think
that was
really super interesting so that will be
linked in the show notes below the lost
connections.com
johan's fantastic instagram and his
twitter will be linked there as well so
you can go on and
just so you know chris i i know someone
who knows judy dench so when this is
live
i am going to send this i'm going to say
forward this to judy
timestamp that point where chris said
that he would [ __ ] judy dench that is
what a way to finish this podcast do you
have any idea how happy she's going to
be she's going to be like those bonobos
no please make it stop
um look thanks so much for coming on man
i really really appreciate it and i
am not going to wait two years after
your next book publishes to get you back
so i hope that you enjoyed it because
you're coming back on soon
cheers chris thank you so much